most of the rain has passed but gusty
cold winds are still sticking around
we've got weather team coverage tonight
chief meteorologist ted florendo
standing by but we begin with victoria
saha with a look at what some
neighborhoods dealt with today
yeah things are definitely a lot calmer
right now very different from what we
saw just about four hours ago but we
just checked with envy energy and still
more than three thousand people are
without power there was actually more
than 9000 without power when this storm
first started because of those high
winds
early afternoon cold rain poured over
the mountains and into las vegas heavy
fog made it almost impossible to see
into the distance those going up the
mountain roads experienced a bit of
winter wonderland as they got higher up
several inches of snow covered the area
the mountains got enough snow that
safety became a top priority the nevada
department of transportation said no one
was allowed up there without four wheel
drives snow tires or tire chains things
quickly shifted as the snow and wind
picked up back in the city the winds
knocked over every single tree in this
christmas tree lot by fort apache and
flamingo looks like a war zone out here
and you know we just battle it for a
couple days it is what it is we hang out
in our little tiny shack over there and
just hope for the best justin powers
owns noble valley christmas trees he
says he tried to stack the trees up and
weigh them down to fight against the
wind nothing seems to work the wind
always gets us wind speed was at 46
miles per hour
now there were some road closures
because of the snow state route 156 by
lee canyon was closed for a couple of
hours it's since reopened so if you are
planning on going back up to the
mountains tomorrow please check out
those road conditions before you head
out reporting near the strip tonight
victoria saha live local now